il ya eu un sondage qui est paru dans le
figaro il ya quelques jours un sondage
harris interactive et qui indiquait et
c'était pas le premier parce que il y en
a eu d'autres avant que le thème qui
comptait le plus pour les français dans
le choix du vote aux élections
européennes c'était l'immigration
et pourtant la publique arte y en a très
peu parlé
c'est à dire qu' il ya des parties qui
ne parlent presque que de ça comme le
rassemblement national et d'autres qui
n'en parle pas du tout comme comment
marche c'est assez curieux que ce soit
pas devenue un sujet de 2,2 de débat
général christophe de voogd ou est ce
que c'est c'est une fausse impression
mais je pense que on verra peut être on
verra les résultats mais d'avoir fait
l'impasse sur ce sujet n'est peut-être
pas forcément la meilleure idée de la
république en marche premièrement
deuxièmement des autres partis y compris
les partis de gauche ne font pas
l'impasse ils ont une politique pro par
exemple mario aubry est très pro
migration et la tige avec avec ce soir
on dira selon les uns courage soit je
sais quoi enfin bref en tout cas elle
n'affiche donc c'est quand même un sujet
moi je trouve qui est qui est plus
présent peut-être que vous de notre
guide même si en fait là françois-xavier
belhani en parle régulièrement même si
la république en marche
finalement en parle très peu mais je
dirais que c'est plutôt de la république
en marche qui a très peu oui mais comme
c'est effectivement l'un des partis
dominants
on a décidé d'ailleurs de consacrer la
couverture du figaro magazine de ce week
end à ce sujet vous le disiez à gauche
on en parle ça donne d'ailleurs parfois
l'occasion de choc c'est pour ça que la
gauche ne fera rien à saisir brutaux je
propose d'écouter ou de réécouter 7,7
passes d'armes assez vives entre benoît
hamon tête de liste du printemps
républicain et jordan bardella qui
dirige la liste rassemblement national
c'était hier lors d'un débat sur bfm tv
jean pas que nous avons sur le printemps
républicain pourquoi
mais le prêteur public américain
génération pas libre oui aujourd'hui
nous sommes sous la menace claire en
europe comme en france d'une
internationale raciste moi la dictature
de l'émotion de la part de la gauche
franchement j'en ai ras-le-bol je crois
que le véritable humanisme c'est la
fermeté c'est joe jackson ne venaient
pas chez nous parce que nous n'avons
plus rien à vous offrir
nous ne scolarise rompt pas vos enfants
nous ne vous régulariseront pas et nous
ne prendrons pas en charge vos dépenses
de santé
parce que dans mon pays la france j'ai
des milliers et des milliers de pauvres
et je préfère et benoît roque avait une
belle réplique pour accueillir la barre
des la développer voilà je commence à
présenter ses excuses à laurent bouvet
quels animateurs du printemps
républicain qui est sur une liste très
laïque qui n'est pas fort ce qui me
frappe cette de benoît hamon
benoît hamon qui est à la tête de la
liste génération
point s qui est aussi le nom de son
parti c'est comme si lucile schmid on
pouvait parler de l'immigration que de
façon caricaturale outrancière comme le
donne à penser cette cette séquence
en tout cas on voit bien que le
l'incantation sur cette campagne est
extrêmement des ondes sur l'immigration
parce que c'est de l'incantation essaie
d opposition de valeur alors même qu'on
sait que la situation est à la fois
humainement très concrètement à ces
terribles évidemment il est mort en
méditerranée mais aussi la situation de
ceux qui sont en france obligée de se
cacher on sait que dublin ne
fonctionnent pas aussi sur le plan
bureaucratique et technocratique
donc tout ça est absent du débat et ce
sont des oppositions effectivement entre
belles valeurs ou au contraire
enfermement et c'est profondément
frustrant lorsqu'on veut élire des
personnes qui agiront seront compétents
sur ces sujets je trouve qu'à une forme
d'incompétence voilà sur la question
migratoire qui ressort de cette campagne
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup d'associations
ça c'est peut-être pas vu ça parce qu'on
voit surtout les débats télévisés mais
beaucoup d'associations notamment
catholiques se sont mais aussi comme la
cimade d'obédience protestante se sont
mobilisées sur cette question des
réfugiés et d'une manière extrêmement
fort pendant la campagne
pour dire plusieurs choses d'abord qu'il
faut partir des destins concret de ce
que demandent les personnes c'est-à-dire
réhumaniser les choses et ça c'est un
sujet qui court à travers la campagne
c'est à dire que là il ya une opposition
entre benoit - et bardella on a
l'impression que chacun veut refaire sa
santé sur son attitude par rapport aux
migrants mais le sujet c'est au fond
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement et si
la république en marche on n'a pas parlé
je pense que c'est tout simplement parce
que il ya une politique de grande
fermeté affichée avec beaucoup
d'indicateurs qui en fait ne fonctionne
pas donc on met des indicateurs de
reconduite à la frontière ont dit que on
n'accepte plus les dubly nez comme comme
on le programme
et puis en fait on n'arrive absolument
pas à renvoyer qui que ce soit les gens
se cachent et donc il ya une impuissance
concrète des personnes au pouvoir de la
république en marche sur ces sujets et
ceux qui prospère c'est le discours du
front national fin du rassemblement
national qui est en décalage complet
aussi avec les fêtes
donc le problème des politiciens
maintenant c'est qu'ils parlent ils ont
une espèce de psychodrame sur les
migrants qui n'a plus rien à voir ni
avec les réfugiés nez avec les migrants
économiques ni avec les réfugiés
climatiques et ça tout le monde le sent
et et je crois que c'est un facteur
d'impuissance politique qui a fait
l'ensemble des parties j'ai dépassé au
point c'est qu'on parle de sujets de
façon trop trop trop abstraite autres ce
qui est vrai c'est que ce qui a marqué
l'année mandanne la mène
2 le parlement européen depuis 2014
c'est d'une part la brique site vous
l'avez dit mais aussi la crise
migratoire de 2015 ce cas qu'en vérité
une rupture fondamentale avec ses se
pressent millions de migrants qui est
arrivé notamment en allemagne et qui a
profondément bousculé le bousculer le
jeu politique européen et a permis à
booster les partis populistes comme il
n'avait jamais été boostées auparavant
ce qui fait que selon les projections le
par l'afd quand même rentré au parlement
européen sinon vous n'avez jamais vu
depuis 1945 paul à 12% mais il ya neuf
ans ce n'est pas rien on nous avait dit
en 2015 qu'ils allaient gagner les
élections européennes que vous allez
voir que madame merkel allait être bouté
hors du pouvoir quatre ans après le
marché du travail se porte très bien
l'afd non mais ce qui certain s'il faut
le noter quand même mais ce qui est
certain c'est en effet les honda d'après
les projections des populistes entre
guillemets ferait 35% au parlement
européen ça veut dire quand android ou
blu ray leur mise depuis 2014 mais ce
doublement de mise et les dus à la crise
migratoire de 2015
parce que si on regarde on vous l'avait
dit l'époque ils sont très divisés leur
point commun quand même entrain salvini
un builders marine le pen un urban c'est
quand même l'immigration c'est le seul
point commun où ils se retrouvent
finalement et où ils sont d'accord
sinon pour le reste sont pas du tout
d'accord sur poutine ne sont pas
d'accord sur le protectionnisme ne sont
pas d'accord sur des tas de choses
ils sont sur l'écologie sont pas
d'accord mais sur ce sujet là c'est le
point et donc je pense que c'est en
effet ce sera l'enjeu de cette prochaine
mandature au parlement européen
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'attendent les
européens sont là le
l'enquète de la fondapol et bien 68 %
des européens pensent que c'est au
niveau et à l'échelle de l'europe que
doit se régler la question migratoire et
je pense qu'ils ont raison et donc c'est
ça mon avis l'enjeu majeur parce que là
on sent qu'il ya une capacité d'action
collective
là où les états sont impuissants il
fallait suis d'accord que ce à l'échelle
européenne
elle est passée au niveau supranational
qu'on peut régler les problèmes de
l'immigration clairement aucun pays peu
tout seul régler sa part lui-même donc
là vraiment l'europe est nécessaire on
sait qu'il faut revoir dublin qu'il faut
revoir schengen
j'aurais aimé que ce soit un peu plus
présent dans la campagne c'était à peine
évoquée quand vous dites qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de migration de la
campagne a quand même beaucoup de
réparer travers des tâches et on a
entendu des petites musiques qui frôlait
la xénophobie très honnêtement des
roumains qui venait prendre notre job
qui venait volé la richesse française
on oublie de parler de migration en
termes positifs à savoir que ses travers
et h et il apporte aussi beaucoup à la
france qu'on apporte beaucoup à l'europe
de l'est grâce à ce système là et donc
on est incapable aujourd'hui de parler
des migrations en termes positifs
l'immigration est devenue une espèce
d'épouvantail va effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui permet d'allier on va
dire tous les populistes eurosceptiques
mais on est incapable de se rendre
compte que cette immigration elle
profite aussi à la france aussi bien par
les gens qui viennent travailler chez
nous et nous aider et aussi bien aussi
pour le moi je pense j'étais français à
londres
cinq cent mille français à londres s'est
vidé leur jeunesse on a mis beaucoup
d'ambiance cette option
justement tous leurs jeunes partent dans
nos pays une fois je pense que la
hongrie fait pas grand chose non plus
pour retenir sa jeunesse avec avec ses
politiques actuelles donc je comprends
très bien qu'ils aient envie d'aller
profiter du libéralisme dans le reste de
l'europe plutôt que subie à laisser
passer de validation de façon positive
comme vous venez de faire là c'est pas
facile pour un parti politique c'est
peut-être pour ça que en marche et si
discrets ils veulent ni la critique bien
c'est quand même important de le faire
si on veut pas se renfermer et penser
que l'immigration est toujours négative
alors je dis pas qu'il ya pas de
problème je dis pas qu'il faut pas en
parler mais je dis qu'il faut aussi voir
l'autre aspect du sujet qui est le fait
que les travailleurs détachés peuvent
nous aider et j'aurais bien aimé
entendre ce discours un peu plus souvent
dans la campagne de non je crois qu'il
faut le problème du si la raison
je crois que tous des trois raisons
c'est à dire que on en veut terriblement
de pragmatisme ce qui est terriblement
mais en écologie entre parenthèses c'est
pareil entre le moralisme écologique
entre l antenne en réalité il était le
tacle c'est exactement pareil s'excuser
moraline dégouline et qui est contre
productive totalement contreproductive
parce qu'elle agace les gens parce qu'il
voit quand même un certain nombre de
choses il suffit d'aller encore une fois
à la chapelle pour voir que ça ne va pas
ça ne va pas à paris et pas seulement à
paris donc il y à il ya véritablement un
problème de pragmatisme
il y a en effet des situations
d'immigration qui sont tellement
différentes
je veux dire après tout aussi je suis un
arrière-plan l'immigration et est en
effet jean mais aussi et là voilà
exactement mais mais mais on ya tous
l'enjeu est évidemment de l'islam dans
cette affaire et qu'il faut pas non plus
oublier que on a donc tout c'est à tous
tout cela est très compliqué et je
trouve que en france et là c'est
vraiment un problème de notre débat je
dirais on y reviendra peut-être quand on
va reparler du débat en france il ya
vraiment un énorme problème pour avoir
un débat de qualité
l'ajustement comparant avec les pays-bas
ya eu un débat télévisé entre monsieur
rutte le premier ministre et monsieur
baudet on a la peau n'a pas le droit en
france il eu un petit débat la fondation
institut montaigne
il n'y a pas eu ce débat comment
j'aurais trouvé utile où on irait au
fond on a une sorte de cacophonie de 11
personnes qui se coupent la parole qui
racontent n'importe quel fait que muse
qui est qu'ils n'ont aucun sens du des
règles rhétorique
moi je suis atterré par le niveau de nos
hommes politiques à quelques exceptions
près et est encore une fois aux pays bas
il ya eu un débat de qualité
démocratique d'où le résultat peut-être
je voulais juste dire une chose par
rapport à ce que disait maxime sur le
fait qu'il faut une architecture
européenne sur la question des migrants
sans doute mais il ne faut pas oublier
deux choses d'abord personne n'a le
pouvoir au niveau européen d'obliger les
états à appliquer cette architecture
donc tout le monde dit il faut un truc
européen parce que tout le monde voit
bien que c'est un phénomène qui englobe
l'ensemble de l'europe
mais le sujet c'est la détermination des
états à coopérer entre eux et la
deuxième chose c'est la capacité à faire
concrètement les choses par rapport au
fait que ces micro économique la
migration ce sont des destins
individuels
les personnes sont là elles ne sont pas
là et donc vous pouvez construire toutes
les architectures que vous voulez mais
vous n'arriverez à rien si vous
n'arrivez pas à voir un maillage avec
des associations de la solidarité
j'aurais aussi dire une chose par
rapport au caractère positif de la
migration faut aussi se rappeler des
devoirs qui sont les nôtres en matière
de réfugiés
c'est la convention de genève il faut à
la fois accueillir certes ceux qui ont
leur place économiquement mais il faut
aussi accueillir ceux qui ont été
persécutés chez eux les femmes qui ont
été violées
sauf que ceux qui ont été torturés je
pense maintenant m'éloigne ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on parle beaucoup sur
le plan positif de la question
économique mais rappelons nous de notre
devoir en termes s'assurer migrer et son
maître majorité insectes ravageurs et je
suis vous donne la parole maxime à noa
noa nos internautes ont là on vous a
posé la question est-ce que selon vous
l'immigration est un des enjeux occulté
de ces européennes de vous êtes plutôt
enclin à répondre oui mme babineau
ajoute que c'est vrai que la république
en marche a été très discrète sur ce
sujet et puis cet avis tranchés de r34
françois-xavier bella me paraît poser
est intelligent mais son parti sur
l'immigration se couche devant les
immigrationnistes maxime ce bail alors
c'est pas pour réagir sur sur cette
cette remarque vaut intéressante non
c'est on parlait de l'exemple allemand
tout à l'heure c'est très intéressant de
voir qu'en allemagne l'immigration n'est
pas du tout un sujet central de la
campagne des européennes
on aurait pu penser qu'avec ce qui s'est
passé en 2015 encore une fois on nous
avait promis que l'allemagne allait
jamais pouvoir relever ce défi c'est le
plus gros défi depuis là depuis la
réunification en allemagne on le dit pas
assez souvent mais l'allemagne est en
train de réussir cette énorme challenge
d'intégrer sur son marché du travail
entre 800 mille et un million de
réfugiés
et ça marche ils sont en train de le
faire ça fait quatre ans et je crois que
la moitié d'entre eux est déjà dans une
forme ou de formation ou d'emploi et
pour autant ça n'est pas un sujet
central c'est-à-dire que nous en france
qui avons accueilli
je croise étaient 7000 réfugiés si ma
mémoire est bonne on parle de
travailleurs détachés mais c'est
intéressant de voir les du coup c'est
quand même une des grosses très
française
mine de rien quand on compare à
l'allemagne quand on regarde l'allemagne
on pourrait s'attendre à ce que ce soit
l'inversé que ce soit l'allemagne qui
parlent plus d'immigration qui en fasse
un sujet central c'est pas du tout le
cas
quand vous regardez les six
organisations marché du travail je vous
parle la campagne européenne comme
rennes les affiches les slogans et les
débats c'est ce sont des débats positifs
ça parle de l'europe
ça explique pourquoi on doit rester tous
ensemble face à la chine et aux états
unis et nous ici on parle encore une
fois dans la rue ontario négatif sur un
problème français là dessus est ce que
cette campagne
elle vous êtes globalement d